[Music]
last night I dreamed about the
Greenfield
where I could build whatever I wanted to
no constraints or workarounds in that
Moment of Zen but
my pager woke me and I knew
I'm living in a legacy land modernizing
whatever I can while the past is always
chasing me we missed a payment on our
technical debt but we haven't defaulted
yet we're gonna see if we can out
entropy
here in Legacy land
[Music]
last week the bill server fell over
again
it's leaking memory but hey our
we're on an agile Journey someone tell
me when we there I still see the
waterfall
I found some code that caused me
physical pain
and ancient clues of sheer incompetency
[Music]
turns out the guy who made the mess was
me I'm living in a legacy land duct tape
stuck to my sweaty hands and nothing
seems ideal with weird Acquisitions
coming into the fold and temporary fixes
that are 10 years old but still
worshiping something real
you're in Legacy land remember the
people who made those long ago technical
decisions were doing the best with the
resources they had and what they built
is still here
worked that's what Legacy means and we
celebrate that even as we work to make
it better
[Music]
now
we're living in Legacy land it's messy
and weird but on the other hand the
esso's most of reality and slowly surely
whenever I do get done in something new
well if I'm lucky the best reward will
be a whole new Legacy
[Music]
I'm living in a legacy land